the announcement was made that we
detected a gravity wave from a distant
object that has a lot of had a very big
or catastrophic gravity event millions
of years ago and the gravity wave showed
up here now gravity wave obviously how
hard could it be so when we do
experiments on light to detect particles
we detect particles of light when we do
experiments on light to detect waves we
detect waves of light when we look at
forces that's the transmission of or the
force over a distance is the
transmission of energy so we can find
energy travelling in waves we can try
and find energy traveling in packets or
particles so people have speculated
since well this is the hundredth
anniversary of Einstein's publishing his
landmark papers people have speculated
on the nature of gravity now I
understand we we understand gravity and
extraordinary with extraordinary
precision we land spacecraft on Mars
precisely everybody watching this has
probably used a global positioning
system on his or her phone or in a car
or in a airplane that's navigating with
global positioning those satellites that
enable this system to work rely on both
special relativity which is the
influence of the speed of the spacecraft
relative to the airplane or ground and
general relativity which is this the
speed of time as affected by the Earth's
gravity so people suspected or
speculated that there will be waves of
gravity and waves of gravity would date
back to the Big Bang to the origin of
the universe 13.7 billion years ago but
they're very weak extraordinarily weak
compare how easy it is to use chemical
energy to hold a ball up against the
pull of gravity or just hold yourself
upright against the pole
gravity gravity of the forces of nature
is the weakest one and so if it its
energy or force or influence moves at
the speed of light like everything else
does does it move in waves well to
detect them you need an extraordinarily
sensitive instrument crazy sensitive
because this influence is so weak and we
did it we set up instrument in Louisiana
and in Washington State
using these mirrors and there's the
gravity wave passed through the earth
the mirrors moved and with
extraordinarily sensitive measurement of
the waves of reflected laser light we
were able to detect this small movement
these small movements and so what does
that mean for us well I don't know but
the discovery of relativity led to
global positioning systems and the
internet and our ability to plant crops
with precision and feed 7.3 billion
people where ever used to only feed 1.5
billion people so who knows where this
discovery will lead but I wouldn't be
surprised if it leads to a new
understanding of another aspect of
physics and a new source of energy or we
prove to ourselves that there is no
other source of energy and we got to
rely on wind and solar or what have you
who knows what it will lead to but the
basic research is worth celebrating this
is a society that uses its intellect and
treasure to make discoveries about
nature and ultimately where we all fit
into the cosmos our place in space so if
you're a human able to hear this
broadcast or watch this broadcast
celebrate it humans have made another
discovery about the universe it's not
bad
you